starting off this hour is gonna be Alan
in Green Bay Wisconsin hi Alan how are
you hi Dave I'm doing good how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
okay so I'm a senior in college right
now we'll be graduating a couple months
and I guess just since I've started
watching your show a lot I've been
looking into budgeting and you know
looking at my finances and stuff and how
I'm gonna pay off the student loans that
I've taken out well I've been in college
and while doing that I found out that my
mom has been in charge of all my
finances and I found out that she's been
taking a lot of money that we've been
taking out for loans for you know her
own expenses and not stuff that's been
related to me at all so I guess I just
want to know if you had any advice for
me how I can kind of go about this
figuring out how I can pay this back and
also how I can deal with the situation
and not like totally ruin my
relationship with my mother
Wow so how much of your money has she
stolen
I actually made about 10 to 12 thousand
mm-hmm and how much is your total
student loan debt 25 okay
and so if you the way you grew up in
this dysfunctional household if you were
to sit down with her and say hey why'd
you steal $12,000 of my money what would
she say right it's just it's been really
weird lately
I saw the part which I saw twelve
thousand dollars from me but okay right
yeah yeah I do try to talk to her you
know she gets emotional know she's
really been struggling with money lately
and I understand that but just the thing
is she hasn't you know we haven't had
this conversation that you know she's
using my through much in long doings
like that so that's where like the major
issue is have you have you taken all of
your financial control away from her
I have not yet no okay
well that's the first thing you have to
do is stop the bleeding you need to take
you need to shut down any account that
has her name on it or it has access to
her in any way and you need to open your
own accounts sir and BA you know leave
them along grown-up and handle your own
money at this point you don't have a
choice and so yeah you've got it you got
to limit her access to your stuff
because she's not trustworthy I'm so
sorry this is so heartbreaking for you
and it puts you in such a extremely
emotional position when somebody
violates your boundaries like this this
is financial child abuse is what it is
okay it happens more often than they
should I run into scum balls who open
credit cards in their kids names and
trash their kids credit steal their own
children's identity in other words
because they somehow feel entitled to
steal someone else's money and you've
got to get pretty twisted in the brain
to be able to do that I mean it says if
you had a shoebox of $25,000 sitting on
your bed with your name on it and it was
your money and she reached in there and
took half of it but she doesn't see it
that way
somehow in her brain she's figured out
that this is okay it ain't okay so um
you know I I you know the only thing I
mean the extreme one extreme is to press
criminal charges the other extreme is
just forget it and pay it yeah in
between would be her promising to repay
but she's out of control that's a
promise that won't be kept
mm-hmm so you probably are left with two
pretty extreme options and one is to
just say I got $25,000 in student loan
debt and I'm coming out of college I'm a
senior and I'm gonna go pay it off or
you can look at prosecuting her the
problem with prosecuting someone
criminally is the money's already gone
and it doesn't make them have the money
to give you money back the more that's
just gone it's just gone and you're
gonna have a real hard time legally
getting the student loans removed from
your name due to theft
that's a very difficult legal set of
Hoops probably cost you more than 12
grand to do it yeah in legal fees so I'm
thinking you're eating this but except
to the extent that you can get something
out of it for her
out of her so I don't know man I'm sorry
I just might like my brain can't wrap
around somebody doing this to their own
freakin kid but I so I'm trying to help
you here and not not Joker she has she
has like admitted that she you know
she's done wrong and she owes me money
just like I'll ask for it or I like want
to talk about it and she says you know
she doesn't have money I doesn't what to
do yeah ok so what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna sit down where there really
calmly but very clearly and say number
one if you ever use my name in any way
to put money in your pocket again I will
criminally prosecute you you need to
tell her that now because she needs to
stop because she'll steal your ID too
and open up a credit card I mean because
she's desperate and she's a little crazy
I mean people don't steal from their own
kids who aren't crazy man I mean really
think about that so you know she's
probably got good attributes all than
that I know I'm talking about your
mother but I mean you you need look at
this realistically so the first part of
the conversation is never again mom the
second part of the conversation is I'm
gonna forgive this I'm gonna pay the
debt I'm gonna forget about it
you pay me back if you can but the only
way I'm gonna do that is you get control
of your life and you're going through
Financial Peace University and I will
pay for it and I will give it to you so
you can give it to her because she needs
to learn how to handle money so she
doesn't keep doing doesn't keep stealing
yeah cuz I don't know where her Thera is
gonna end if we don't that's because
she's gonna end up in jail right because
if you do this with a bank they
prosecute you you know if you guys are
though if you do this with check kiting
they prosecute you this is not this is
not a game I mean this is not a family
affair this is criminal activity so for
her sake we got to get her under control
because she's completely spiraling here
if you can and then I think
realistically you're probably some mom
you pay me back all this money and just
leave it on her to do that but then you
have any low X emotional expectation
that that's going to occur because
practically thinking I don't think
you're ever gonna see it does that make
sense yeah yeah so what is your degree
field that you're studying marketing
good for you okay yeah and you graduate
any other job set up I have a job set up
for when I graduate I'm gonna start
working right away making making pretty
good money so making what making so much
hot oven how much for your thousand 4000
good you have any other debt other than
this twenty five thousand nope okay well
you're a sharp young man and you have a
story to tell your grandkids about how
we don't behave in this family any
longer because you're gonna be able to
clean this up and I'll tell you what I'm
going to put both of you into Financial
Peace University you and Mom if she'll
promise to go and promise to repay you
but have a low expectation of the second
part occurring hold on Kelly's going to
pick up this is the Dave Ramsey show